lastly in our tour of unhinged illusion
in reaction to the news of pom anaphors
indictment I try really hard to apply
the same standard to all leaks I think
it's fine to explore the legality of the
leaks themselves and I tend to focus on
the content of the leaks right so when
the DNC had those email leaks I
commented on the nature of how the leaks
happened and then we focused on the
content when it was the Trump Russia
leaks I mentioned how we got it and then
I focused on the content but most
politicians and especially Republicans
they want to focus on how the leak
happened if the content is really bad
for them and they want to focus only on
the content if how the leak happened is
bad for them and Chris Christie's doing
exactly that Chris Christie was
interviewed by Jake Tapper on CNN and he
immediately goes into well the fact that
something leaked might be criminal
here's chris Christie trying to explain
it to you
so CNN broke the news this weekend that
Bob Muller's grand jury has approved its
first charges as a former US Attorney do
you think president Trump's associates
should be worried about what might be
about to unfold well listen I think
anybody who's been advised by the
special counsels office that they're a
target of the investigation which I'm
sure he has done to those people who are
should be concerned and I'll tell you
what we else we should be concerned
about tell us no the fact that that CNN
has this information as you know Jake
there are very very strict laws on grand
jury secrecy and so depending upon who
leaked this to CNN that's a criminal
violation well listen I'm sure that'll
be looked into but these are the
indictments that Republicans said were
never coming they were swearing up and
down we will never have these
indictments now we have them so let's
talk about whether we should arrest
someone for telling CNN about this and
later Christie said that the leaking
wasn't tasteful tasteful he closed a
bridge for political retribution and a
woman died because an ambulance couldn't
get her medical help quickly enough and
he's worried about whether this leak is
tasteful and does anyone think for a
second that this is actually going to
work that once the indictment is out as
it now is with its 12 counts its 12
charges against man afford that you'll
be able to take attention away from it
by saying hey the fact that we knew
about it 72 hours before it went
that's the problem and of course that's
not the storyline today the story line
today from the ideologically committed
trumpets is this doesn't involve Trump
and it doesn't involve the campaign and
we'll see how long that holds up I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show we'll be back after
this
today's program is made possible in part
by the Hercules app at Hercules app.net
and on the Google Play Store it's hard
enough to stick with a workout and to
know what it is that you're doing and a
big part of being successful in losing
fat or gaining muscle or staying healthy
is keeping track of your progress and
your performances along the way in order
to achieve your goals and that's exactly
what the Android app Hercules has been
designed to do you can easily set your
goals you tap on the play button once it
will guide you through your workout you
can record your performances during rest
times with one touch and Hercules will
also compute calories burned and draw
charts of your progress to actually keep
you motivated along the way to reach
your goals it's accessible to beginners
and it's great for advanced users very
customizable it's packed with more than
200 predefined exercises and it supports
both super sets and CrossFit workouts
natively you can check out the Hercules
app on the Play Store right now or visit
the website at Hercules app.net to learn
more Hercules is free to download with
full features try it for seven days and
buy it for a one-time fee under 10 bucks
if you like it including updates for
free forever that is Hercules app.net
the best workout tracker on Android
download it from the Play Store and you
can also click the link in the YouTube
video description below